Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I cannot believe that this paper is here. This
is unbelievable. So, what is going on here? Yes,
that’s right, we know that these modern
AI programs can paint images for us,
anything we wish, but today, we are going to find
out whether they can also do it with video. You
see an example here, and here. Are these also
made by an AI? Well, I’ll tell you in a moment.
So, video? That sounds impossible. That is so much
harder! You see, videos require a much greater
understanding of the world around us, so much more
computation, and my favorite, temporal coherence.
What is that? This means that a video is not just
a set of images, but a series of images that have
to relate to each other. If the AI does not do
a good job at this, we get this. Flickering.
So, as all of this is so hard, I thought, we
will be able to do this maybe in 5-10 years, or
maybe never? Well, scientists at Google say not so
fast. Now hold on to your papers, and have a look
at this. Oh my goodness! Is it really here? I am
utterly shocked, but the answer is yes. Yes it is!
So now, let’s have a look at 3 of my
favorite examples, and then I’ll tell
you how much time this took. By the way,
it is an almost unfathomably short time.
Now, one, the concept is the same: one simple text
prompt goes in, for instance, a happy elephant
wearing a birthday hat walking under the sea, and
this comes out. Wow. Look at that! That is exactly
what we were asking for in the prompt, plus, as
I am a light transport researcher by trade, I am
also looking at the waves and the sky through the
sea, which is absolutely beautiful, but it doesn’t
stop there - I also see every light transport
researcher’s dream there. Water caustics. Look
at these gorgeous patterns. Now, not even this
technique is perfect, you see that temporal
coherence is still subject to improvement, the
video still flickers a tiny bit, the tusk is also
changing over time. However, this is incredible
progress in so little time. Absolutely amazing.
Two, in good Two Minute Papers fashion, now
let’s ask for a bit of physics, a bunch of
autumn leaves falling on a calm lake forming
the text “Imagen Video”. I love it. You see,
in computer graphics, creating a
simulation like this would take
quite a bit of 3D modeling knowledge, then,
we also have to fire up a fluid simulation.
Now, this does not seem to do a great deal of
two-way coupling, which means that the water has
an effect on the leaves, you see it advecting
this leaf here, but the leaves do not seem to
have a huge effect on the water itself. This
is possible with specialized computer graphics
algorithms like this one, and I bet it will
also be possible with Imagen Video 2. Now,
I am super happy to see the reflections of
the leaves appearing on the water. Good job,
little AI! And to think that this is
just the first iteration of Imagen Video,
wow. By the way, if you wish to see how
detailed a real physics simulation can be,
make sure to check out my Nature Physics comment
paper in the video description. Spoiler alert:
the surprising answer is that they can
be almost as detailed as real life.
I was also very happy with this
splash. And with this turquoise
liquid’s movement in the glass too. Great
simulations on version 1. I am so happy!
Now, three, give me a teddy bear
doing the dishes. Whoa! Is this real?
Yes it is! It really feels like we are living
inside a science fiction movie. Now, it’s not
perfect, you see that it is a little confused by
the interaction of these objects, but if someone
told me a few weeks ago that an AI would be able
to do this, I wouldn’t have believed a word of
it. It not only has a really good understanding
of reality, but it can also combine two previous
concepts, a teddy bear and washing the dishes
into something new. My goodness. I love it.
Now, while we look at some more beautiful results,
we noted that this is incredible progress in
so little time. But, how little exactly? Well,
if you have been holding on to your
papers so far, now, squeeze that paper,
because the OpenAI’s DALL-E 2 text to image AI
appeared in April 2022, then, Google’s Imagen,
also text to image appears one month later, May
2022, that is incredible, and get this, now, only
5 months later, by October 2022, we get this.
An amazing text to video AI. I am out of words!
Of course, it is not perfect, the hair
of pets is typically still a problem,
and the complexity of this ship battle is
still a little too much for it to shoulder,
so version one is not going to make
a new Pirates of The Caribbean Movie,
but maybe version 3 two more
papers down the line? Who knows?
Ah yes, about that. The resolution of these
videos is not too bad at all, it is in 720p,
the literature likes to call it high definition.
These are not in 4k like the shows you can watch
on your tv, but this quality for a first crack
the at the problem is simply stunning. And don’t
forget that first, it synthesizes a low-resolution
video, then upscales it through super resolution,
something Google is already really good at,
so I would not be surprised for version 2
to easily go to full HD, and maybe even beyond.
As you see, the pace of progress in AI research
is nothing short of amazing. If like me,
you are yearning for some more results,
you can check out the paper’s website in the video
description where as of the making of this video,
you get a random selection of results. Refresh
it a couple times and see if you get something
new! And if I could somehow get access to this
technique, you bet that I’d be generating a ton
more of these. Update: I cannot make any promises,
but, good news, we are already working on it.
A video of a scholar reading exploding papers
absolutely needs to happen. Make sure to subscribe
and hit the bell icon to not miss it in case
it happens! You really don’t want to miss that.
So, from now on, if you are wondering what a
wooden figurine surfing in outer space looks like,
you need to look no further. What a time
to be alive! So, what do you think? Does
this get your mind going? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!